hello everyone and welcome to the last
game we will be showing from round 10
round 11 started already but i didn't
have time to uh make uh uh uh coverage
of this one yesterday so i'm doing it
now hope you guys don't mind but it is a
very important one to cover so now let's
dive straight into it it's
versus being lyran and it is quite the
game we talked a little bit about it in
the previous video now let's see what
actually happened uh the opening uh
pretty standard uh we have e4 e5 knight
to f3 knight to c6 and the bishop to b5
the real opus is on the board
sorry about that
and before we uh dive uh deeper into the
real opus we also have a nice photo of
this encounter there you have it the
first move being made by
alexandre costeneuk
so let's um check it out uh
before we enjoy the game there you have
it as you guys have requested more
photos uh and uh of course a6 morphe's
defense with bishop to a4 uh knight to
f6 and now d3 the anderson variation you
guys know why it's called that because
you've seen the paul morphy saga
b5 bishop to b3 and bishop to c5 now we
have bishop to g5 again all been played
before h6 bishop to h4 and d6 with c3 uh
and the bishop back to a7 castles and
now knight to a5 going after the bishop
so very standard
lopezian stuff you guys uh all know this
we have bishop to c2 and now we entered
the game that was played uh only once
before between fabiana corona and john
burke last year in 2021 in the usa usa
championship uh that fabi won burke
tried the g5 here and it is a very good
attempt it is in fact the absolute top
move recommended by the engine but the
ding goes for c5 it is uh well that
depends on how long you uh allow the
engine to change its mind like at the
depth 35 it's going to say g5 at depth
36 is going to say b5
or rather c5 at 37 is going to say g5 38
is going to say c5 so the engine can't
really make up its mind so it's hard to
say how deep ding analyzed it but he
said all right this was already tried
against fabi
uh in the u.s
championship uh let's go with c5 and it
is now as of movie 11 that we have a
completely new game rapport continues
development knight beat to d2 and only
now pawn to g5 we have bishop to g3 and
not knight to h5 so putting pressure on
the bishop but also in some lines maybe
the knight wants to come to f4
we have a3 now preparing b4 and rook to
b8 and this is very interesting usually
when you have a position like this
you're thinking how do i get rid of the
light square bishop so i can play rook
to c8 well ding wants to put the rook on
the c file but he's not um you know all
that uh interested in the light square
bishop he's gonna play rogue v8 rook b7
rook to c7 that's how ding's going to do
it king to h1 it's important to get the
king away from this diagonal you want to
move the knight you want to strike with
f4 at some point and so on so rogue b7
and pawn to b4 challenging the knight
here grabbing more space on the queen
side knight to c6 and now bishop to b3
the rook also very useful here uh
guarding the seventh rank and that f7
weakness as you know if the idf file
opens up it could be a problem
but ding decided to keep the king in the
center of the board now you could castle
here it's possible but ding says nope
we're keeping the king in the center
rook the c7 uh bishop to d5 now
and uh pawn to g4 now challenging the
knight we have bishop to h4 attacking
the queen first knight to e7 and now
knight back to g1 we have c captures on
b4 and now uh rapport could go for uh uh
c captures on b4 and even though you
always want to capture towards the
center this kind of comes with upon
sacrifice if you play eight captures on
b4 uh but thinks uh ding's king is in
the center of the board so uh rapport
not interested in counting pawns he
plays eight captures on b4 also this
gives his a a a rook d semi-open a file
so rook captures on c3 and now knight to
e2 attacking the rook rogue back to c7
and now f4 not wasting any time he wants
to go after ding's king
f6 biting f captures an e5 d captures
and now knight the g3 attacking the
knight on h5 sodium traits knight
captures and not bishop captures but h
characters he wants the bishop to keep
attacking the f6 pawn uh rook to f8
biting and now rook captures on f6 rook
captures bishop captures and queen to d6
now attacking the bishop and what can
what can rapper do here well he plays
queen to f1
uh defends the bishop and now bishop to
d4 uh
and again what can you do here how can
you improve uh your position increase
the pressure how do you create some
attacking chances with the dings king
still being an e8 well we reach the
position from the thumbnail bishop to f7
with check and now of course the king
cannot capture the bishop if you capture
then we open up a discovery here and we
pick up the black queen also queen here
this is also guarded by the bishop and
the queen
so instead king to d7 uh by ding getting
out of check and now rook to d1
preparing to move the knight and then
attack the bishop then push the pawn
open up the
the d file and attack the black king so
rook the c 2 by ding and now bishop back
to b3 attacking the rook here
and ding plays rook back to c7
we have knight to c4 that's the good
stuff this is the move that you guys
probably thought that i was going to use
as a thumbnail and i thought about it
but i decided to go with the bishop to
f71 as i don't know it's kind of nicer
uh or if you don't want to go for this
you you could also just repeat bishop f7
rook c2 bishop to b3 and both of them
would very likely agree to a draw but
rapport once more he has the white
pieces and he's not letting ding off the
hook that easy the king is on d7 i mean
look at that light square bishop we are
not again we're not calling this a draw
so knight to c4 attacking the queen and
you don't really have a good move if you
capture here then we go after the e5
pawn and that king will be wide in the
open uh you know
and not something you want to play so
ding accepts the sacrifice and he says
let's play pawn capture spawn captures
and now uh what is uh what is that
upwards actual threat here well let's
play a silly move let's say h5 and see
what it is it's c5 this is our upwards
threat and if ding allows this thing can
resign the queen now has to move we're
going to capture the e5 pawn you're not
going to be able to capture back and
without this pawn bishop uh
barrier in the center of the board
edding's position just crumbles so after
this d captures in c4 this has to
somehow uh deal with this and he finds a
very nice idea rook the c6 now c5
doesn't work because we just captured
the bishop that's the point but it also
allows the bishop to a4 why why did the
ding allow this well because this is
also good for ding it is in fact the
strongest move that rapper can play but
it is the best move that the ding has so
the rapper goes for the rook and the
king the c7 again you can't push the
pawn because the bishop would hang so
here we have to capture the exchange
bishop captures knight captures on c6
and now pawn to b5 continuing to push
the pawns knight to b4 and now pawn to
c5 beautiful pawn pushing technique by
rapport
the bishop cannot capture because the
queen hangs if queen captures then rook
to c1 again will be very very
problematic so queen to e6 by ding and
now just bishop back to h4 and now how
do you play this bishop captures on c5
we eliminate some of the pawns here
but still the king is wide in the open
rook the c1 attacks the bishop queen to
d6 defends the bishop and queen to c4
yet again attacks the bishop we have
knight to d3 now defending the bishop
and here
rook to c3 attacking the knight here
threatening to just pick it up
and it's a very very difficult position
uh to play for for ding you have to play
it very very precisely otherwise you're
just going to lose but there is one move
that allows you to seek advantage and
even play for the win so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
idea while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that you
do not need this knight and the bishop's
pair is all uh
you need to win this game and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is of course a captures and b5 you we
grabbed that
and uh now uh well we we offer the
knight but we don't care we're gonna
start pushing our past pawn and that
will be sufficient i forgot to mention
uh instead of this uh uh idea of uh rook
the c3 you could also just play bishop
to e7 uh that that move actually allows
rapper to kind of force a draw here uh
because uh well what do you play if
queen captures now we capture the knight
on d3 and if king to b6 we're just going
to play b captures on a6 and after
bishop captures let's say queen d5 and
the king is on b6 completely in the open
uh you're not going to be able to get
out of checks but okay rook to c3 was
played and ding goes for the absolute
strongest a captures on b5
offering the
uh the knight here if if you play queen
captures on b5 it's nothing serious just
bishop to a6 and then black is better so
this is the only tri queen characters on
the three queen captures rook captures
and now bishop to d4 again the only
winning idea for ding you have to cover
the b2 square and now the pawn will
start marching forward we're going to
also cover this diagonal so it's not a
problem and this bishop here is doing
nothing even though rapport is up the
exchange it doesn't matter now we have
bishop to f6 still with one last trick
let's say if ding pushes b4 then we have
rook to b3 and after the bishop c3 move
we have bishop to e7 that's the idea uh
so i think of course figures this out
king the b6 is played we have rook
capture sunday for as now you really
don't have anything better the king and
and the the bishops will simply escort
the pawn down the board so rook captures
here uh and now he captures on d4 bishop
captures on d4 now it's uh equal
material opposite colored bishops which
usually you know tends to be a draw but
not not here king to a5 getting out of
check king to g1 the the white king is
uh so so far away from all the action
pawn to be for king f2 now comes king to
a4 king the e3 king to b3 and now king
to f4 we have king to c2 king to e5 and
now pawn to b3 king to d6 we have king
to d3 attacking the bishop bishop to a1
and the king captures on a4 it doesn't
matter how you play this king c5 king to
d3 and it was in this position that we
have rapport resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here uh your
g4 pawn is defended by the light square
bishop so of course once you give up
this bishop for the pawn it's all over
let's say we play a few more moves king
b4 king c2 bishop somewhere or anything
we're just going to push it upon you're
going to have to capture it in order to
avoid
you know
playing against the queen and now we
simply have this pawn guarded we're
gonna gobble up these pawns and that's
it we're gonna escort this pawn down the
border we don't even need this pawn well
white can uh you know capture it so it's
completely winning ding uh rapport of
course doesn't want to play this and
here he resigns on move 55 we even have
a nice photo of the resignation so here
it is you can see a nice handshake um
not the firmest of handshakes uh but you
know it's uh it's a nice one considering
uh the game and the
situation in the candidates tournament
so there you have it and also for maybe
those of you who haven't seen the
standings in the previous videos uh here
are the standings after round ten uh
yanipong she extended his lead by a full
point and a half then we have a
three-way tie between fabiano karwana
hikaru nakamura and ding liran
and we have arajava one four and a half
uh duda rapport and firuja
sharing last place basically with four
out of ten
uh so yeah that's the game some photos
and the standards hope you guys enjoyed
that today is round 11 where the leader
yanni pomnishi will be uh facing alireza
furuja who is currently in last place so
uh he has nothing to lose he has the
white pieces against the leader nepo
will he go for it i'm sure that he will
because i've already seen some of the
moves uh so i think we're in for uh for
a great game uh but yeah that's it i
hope you guys enjoyed it i would like to
wish a very happy birthday to nashi and
i would like to thank uh clever piggy
ordol and ferdi uh forever um uh michael
hope consulting and uh alan chevalier
moore for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates until it finishes so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day uh and if
you're wondering where meadow is he's
actually uh right here uh you know
sometimes uh he's on the couch sometimes
he's he's on the floor he's just like
that uh you know
he he does what he wants that's right
see you soon